laissez les collégiens s'exprimer à
travers l'art c'est le but du projet
graff mis en place par le conseil
départemental dans neuf collèges de
l'île à s'entendre et la classe 307 du
collège mille roches a inauguré sa
fresque de l'art urbain réalisé par les
élèves avec la contribution de leur
professeur d'arts plastiques et d'un
artiste alors c'est un projet qui a
démarré avec les élèves en décembre 2014
et donc on a commencé d'abord par tout
un travail de recherche et de
transmission d'informations sur
l'histoire du graff la naissance du
graff l'origine du graff guen l'artiste
a apporté son savoir faire à cette
classe de troisième enchanté par le
travail réalisé avec les élèves
cet artiste se dit ravi de l'engouement
suscité chez les jeunes j'ai rencontré
cette classe la 307 voilà du collège de
mille roches et on a commencé à
travailler sur ce projet dans tous
ensemble voilà le but c'était vraiment
que quiconque y fasse ce travail du
début à la fin c'est à dia qui fasse
toute l'étape de recherche
deux dessins de croquis et après avant
la réalisation et qui apprend aux fastes
où la réalisation ensemble à c'est une
super classe franchement c'était une
super classe j'ai fait beaucoup
d'ateliers et je dois dire que cette
classe a vraiment été super ils ont
donné de tous ils ont été très présents
ils ont bien écouté des élèves fiers
d'avoir participé à l'embellissement de
leur collège et des parents qui vont en
ce projet une véritable démarche
éducative
on est tous vraiment très beau on a tous
travaillé ensemble pour finaliser le
projet et on s'est décidé à s'éviter
tout ça c'est grâce à monsieur gwan
on est fiers de nous on est vraiment
fier en est et dans quelques années
qu'on va passer on va dire c'est nous
qui a fait sa grâce à monsieur bourgoin
monsieur peu plus et madame francs et
les autres qui ont participé ça vient du
coeur c'est la seule chose que je peux
vous dire
éducative par les sanctions comme l'a
dit d'ailleurs marché principal il est
toujours très intéressant de travailler
sur le thème de la dérive à rentrer dans
un établissement
je pense que c'est la meilleure pas
certes l'ouverture de l'esprit et le
réveil de la qualité de nos enfants on a
beau ici des nuits par an
aux cris de les pousser vers plein de
choses que ce soit de ce peuple
la musique la peinture mais quand c'est
comme ça en mise en valeur dans
l'établissement scolaire
c'est donc très importants et d'autant
plus enrichissant certainement heureux
le conseil départemental a doté le
collège d'une subvention de 5000 euros
afin de permettre la mise en oeuvre du
projet le rôle de la collectivité c'est
tout d'abord devises et à
l'épanouissement n'élève
l'accomplissement de son de
l'accompagnement plus exactement durant
ses quatre années de collège et en
mettant en place dont des dotations
financières permettant de la réalisation
de ce type de projet est aussi de mettre
en relation les établissements avec des
partenaires que sont le sérieux en
l'occurrence sur ce projet là des
graffeurs et c'est l'ensemble des
partenaires qui arrive au résultat que
vous avez aujourd'hui